the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
good afternoon everybody welcome to
lecture eight so we're now more than
halfway through the lectures all right
the topic of today is sampling I want to
start by reminding you about this whole
business of inferential statistics we
make references about populations by
examining one or more random samples
drawn from that population we use Monte
Carlo simulation over the last two
lectures and the key idea there as we
saw in trying to find the value of pi
was that we can generate lots of random
samples and then use them to compute
confidence intervals and then we use the
empirical rule to say alright we really
have good reason to believe that 95% of
the time we run this simulation our
answer will be between here and here
well that's all well and good when we're
doing simulations but what happens when
you have to actually sample something
real for example you run an experiment
and you get some data points and it's
too hard to do it over and over again
think about political polls here's was
an interesting poll how are these
created not by simulation they didn't
run a thousand polls and then compute
the confidence interval they ran one
poll of a hundred eight hundred and
thirty-five people in this case and yet
they claimed to have a confidence
interval that's what that margin of
error is obviously they needed that
large confidence interval so how is this
done well it's backing up for a minute
let's talk about how sampling is done
when you are not running a simulation
you want to do what's called probability
sampling
in which each member of the population
has a nonzero probability of being
included in a sample there are roughly
speaking two kinds will spend really all
of our time on something called simple
random sampling and the key idea here is
that each member of the population has
an equal probability of being chosen in
the sample all right so there's no bias
now that's not always appropriate I do
want to take a minute to talk about why
so suppose we wanted to survey MIT
students to find out whether their what
fraction of the more Nerds which by the
way I consider a compliment
so suppose we wanted to consider a
random sample of a hundred students we
could walk around campus and choose a
hundred people at random and if twelve
percent of them were nerds we would say
twelve percent of the MIT undergraduates
are nerd if 98 percent etc well the
problem with that is let's look at the
majors by school you can this is
actually the under the majors at MIT by
school and you can see that they're not
exactly evenly distributed and so if you
went around and just sample a hundred
students at random there'd be a
reasonably high probability that they
would all be from engineering in science
and that might give you a misleading
notion of the fraction of MIT students
that were nerds or it might not in such
situations we do something called
stratified sampling where we partition
the population into subgroups and then
take a simple random sample from each
subgroup and we do that proportional to
the size of the subgroups so we would
certainly want to take more students
from engineering than from architecture
but we probably want to make
sure we got somebody from architecture
in our sample this by the way is the way
most political polls are done they're
stratified they said we want to get so
many rural people so many civil so many
city people so many minorities things
like that and in fact that's probably
where the election recent polls were all
messed up is they did a very
retrospectively at least a bad job of
stratifying so we use stratified
sampling when there are small groups
subgroups that we want to make sure
represented and we want to represent
them proportional to their size in the
population this can also be used to
reduce the needed size of the sample if
we wanted to make sure we got some
architecture students in our sample we
need to get more than a hundred people
to start with but if we stratify we can
take fewer samples it works well when
you do it properly but it can be tricky
to do it properly and we are going to
stick to simple random samples here all
right let's look at a example so this is
a map of temperatures in the United
States and so our running example today
will be sampling to get information
about the average temperatures and of
course as you can see they're highly
variable and we live in one of the
cooler areas the data will be going to
use is real data and it's in the zip
file that I put up for the class from
the US centers for environmental
information and it's got the daily high
and low temperatures for 21 different
American cities every day from 1961
through 2015 so it's a it's an
interesting data set a total of about
four hundred and twenty-two thousand
examples in the data set so a fairly
good-sized data set it's fun to play
with all right so we're sort of
in the part of the course where the next
series of lectures including today is
going to be about data science how to
analyze data I always like to start by
actually looking at the data getting not
looking at all four hundred twenty-one
thousand samples but giving a plots to
sort of give me a sense of what the data
looks like I'm not going to walk you
through the code that does this plot I
do want to point out that there are two
things in it that we may not have seen
before so simply enough I'm going to use
numpy dot STD to get standard deviations
instead of my own code for it and random
dot sample to take simple random samples
from the population random dot sample
takes two arguments the first is some
sort of a sequence of values and the
second is an integer telling you how
many samples you want and it returns a
list containing sample size randomly
chosen distinct elements distinct
elements is important because there are
two ways that people do sampling you can
do sampling without replacement which is
what's done here that you take a sample
and then it's out of the population so
you won't draw out the next time or you
can do sampling with replacement which
allows you to draw the same sample
multiple times the same example multiple
times we'll see later in the term that
there are good reasons that we sometimes
prefer sampling with replacement but
usually we're doing sampling without
replacement and that's what we'll do
here so we won't get Boston on April 3rd
multiple times or not the same year at
least alright so here's the histogram
the code produces you can run it
yourself now if you want or you can run
it later and here's what it looks like
the daily high temperatures the mean is
sixteen point three degrees
Celsius I sort of vaguely know what that
feels like and as you can see it's kind
of an interesting distribution it's it's
not normal but it's not that far right
we have a little tail of these cold
temperatures on the left and it's it's
it is what it is it's not a normal
distribution and will later see that
doesn't really matter okay so this gives
me a sense the next thing I'll get us
some statistics so we know the mean at
16 point 3 and the standard deviation is
approximately nine point four degrees so
if you look at it you can believe that
well here's a histogram of one random
sample of size 100 looks pretty
different as you might expect it's
standard deviation is 10 point 4 it's
mean 17 point o7 so even though the
figures look a little different in fact
the means and standard deviations are
pretty similar if we look at the
population mean and the sample mean and
I'll try and be careful to use those
terms they're not the same but they're
in the same ballpark and the same is
true of the two standard deviations well
that raises the question did we get
lucky or is something we should expect
if we draw a hundred random samples
examples should we expect them to
correspond to the population as a whole
and the answer is sometimes yeah
sometimes no and that's one of the
issues I want to explore today so one
way to see whether it's a happy accent
is to try it a thousand times we can
draw a thousand samples of size 100 and
plot the results
again I'm not going to go over the code
there's something in that code as well
that we haven't seen before and that's
the ax dot V line plotting command V for
vertical it just in this case will draw
a red line because I said the color is R
at population mean on the x-axis so just
a vertical line so that'll just show us
where the mean is if we wanted to draw a
horizontal line we use a X H line just
showing you a couple of useful functions
when we try it a thousand times here's
what it looks like so here we see what
we had originally same picture I showed
you before and here's what we get we
look at the means of a hundred samples
so this plot on the left looks a lot
more like it's a normal distribution the
one on the right should that surprise us
or is there a reason we should have
expected that to happen well what's the
answer someone tell me why we should
have expected it it's because of the
central limit theorem right that's
exactly what the central limit theorem
promised us would happen and sure enough
it's pretty close to normal so that's a
good thing
and now if we look at it we can see that
the mean of the sample means is sixteen
point three and the standard deviation
of the sample means is 0.94 so if we go
back to what we saw here we see that
actually when we run it a thousand times
and look at the means we get very close
to what we exceed it's not a happy
accident it's it's something we can in
general expect all right what's the 95%
confidence interval here well it's going
to be sixteen point two eight plus or
minus 1.96 times zero point nine for the
standard deviation of the sample means
and so it tells us that the confidence
interval is the mean high temperatures
somewhere between 14.5 and eighteen
point one well that's actually a pretty
big range right it's sort of enough to
you to where you wear a sweater you
don't wear a sweater so the good news is
it includes the population mean that's
nice but the bad news is it's pretty
wide suppose we wanted a tighter bound I
said all right sure enough the central
limit theorem is going to tell me the
mean of the means is going to give me a
good estimate of the actual population
mean but I want a tighter bound what can
I do well let's think about a couple of
things we could try well one thing we
could think about is drawing more
samples suppose instead of a thousand
samples I take in
or 3,000 samples we can ask the question
would that have given me a smaller
standard deviation for those of you have
not looked ahead what do you think who
thinks it will give you a smaller
standard deviation who thinks it won't
and the rest of you have either looked
ahead or refused to think I'll prefer to
believe you looked ahead well we can run
the experiment you can go to the code
and you'll see that there's a constant
of a thousand which you can easily
change the 2,000 and lo and behold the
standard deviation barely budges got a
little bit bigger as it happens but that
kind of an accident
it just more or less doesn't change and
it won't change if I go to 3,000 or
4,000 or 5,000 that'll wiggle around but
it won't help much so what we can see is
doing it more often is not going to help
suppose we take larger samples is that
going to help who thinks that will help
and who thinks it won't okay well we can
again run the experiment I did run the
experiment I changed the sample size
from 100 to 200 and again you can run
this if you want and if you run it
you'll get a result maybe not exactly
this but something very similar that
indeed as I increase the size of the
sample rather than the number of the
samples the standard deviation drops
fairly dramatically in this case from
0.94 to 0.66
so that's a good thing I now want to
digress a little bit before we come back
to this and look at how you can
visualize this because this is a
technique you'll want to use as you
write papers and things like that is how
do we visualize the variability of the
data and it's usually done with
something called an error bar you've all
seen these things here and this is one I
took from the literature this is
plotting pulse rate against how much
exercise you do how frequently you
exercise and what you can see here is is
there's definitely a downward trend
suggesting that the more you exercise
the lower your average resting pulse
that's probably worth knowing and these
error bars give us the 95% confidence
intervals for different subpopulations
and what we can see here is that some of
them overlap so yes once a fortnight two
weeks for those of you who don't speak
British
it does get a little bit smaller than
rarely or never but the confidence
interval is very big and so maybe we
really shouldn't feel very comfortable
that it would actually help the thing we
can say is that if the confidence
intervals don't overlap we can conclude
that the means are actually
statistically significantly different in
this case at the 95% level so here we
see that the more than weekly does not
overlap with the rarely or never and
from that we can conclude that this is
actually statistically true that if you
exercise more than weekly your pulse is
likely to be lower than if you don't
if confidence intervals do overlap
you cannot conclude that there is no
statistically significant difference
there might be and you can use other
tests to find out whether there are when
they don't overlap it's a good thing we
can conclude something strong when they
do overlap we need to investigate
further all right let's look at the
error bars for our temperatures and
again we can plot those using something
called pylab dot error bar so what it
takes is two values the usual x-axis and
y-axis and then it takes another list of
the same length or sequence of the same
length which is the Y errors and here
I'm just going to say 1.96 times the
standard deviations where these
variables come from you can tell by
looking at the code and then I can say
the format I want an O to show the mean
and then a label fmt stands for format
error bar has different keyword
arguments than plot you'll find that you
look at different ways like histograms
and bar plots scatter plots they all
have different available keyword
arguments so you have to look up each
individually but other than this
everything in the code should look very
familiar to you and when I run the code
I get this and so what I've plotted here
is the mean against the sample size with
error bars and a hundred trials in this
case so what you can see is that as the
sample size gets bigger the error bars
get smaller
the estimates of the mean don't
necessarily get any better now in fact
we can look here and this is actually a
worse estimate relative to the true mean
than the previous two estimates but we
can have more confidence in it the same
thing we saw on Monday when we looked at
estimating PI dropping more needles
didn't necessarily give us a more
accurate estimate but it gave us more
confidence in our estimate and the same
thing is happening here and we can see
that steadily we can get more and more
confidence so larger samples seem to be
better that's a good thing going from a
sample size of 50 to a sample size of
600 reduce the confidence interval as
you can see from a a fairly large the
confidence interval here ran from just
below 14 to almost 19 as opposed to 15
and a half or so to 17 I said confidence
interval here I should not have I should
have said standard deviations that's an
error on the slides okay
what's the catch well we're now looking
at 100 samples each of size 600 so we've
looked at a total of 600 thousand
examples what does this brought us
absolutely nothing right the entire
population only contained about 422
thousand samples we - well have looked
at the whole thing rather than take a
few of them so it's like you know you
might as well hold an election rather
than ask eight hundred people a thousand
times who they're going to a million
times who they're going to vote for
alright so sure it's good but it gave
nothing suppose we did it only once
suppose we took only one sample as we
see in political polls what can we
conclude from that and the answer is
actually kind of surprising how much we
can conclude in a real mathematical
sense from one sample and again this is
thanks to our old friend the central
limit theorem
so if you recall the theorem it had
three parts up till now we've exploited
the first two we've used the fact that
the means will be normally distributed
so that we could use the empirical rule
to get confidence intervals and the fact
that the mean of the sample means would
be close to the mean of the population
now I want to use the third piece of it
which is that the variance of the sample
means will be close to the variance of
the population divided by the sample
size and we're going to use that to
compute something called the standard
error of the formally the standard error
of the mean people often just call it
the standard error and I will be alas
inconsistent how I sometimes call it one
sometimes the other all right
it's a incredibly simple formula says
the standard error is going to be equal
to Sigma where Sigma is the population
standard deviation divided by the square
root of n which is going to be the size
of the sample
and then there's just this very small
function that implements it so so we can
compute this thing called the standard
error of the mean in a very
straightforward way well we can compute
it but does it work what do I mean by
work I mean what's the relationship of
the standard error to the standard
deviation because remember that was our
goal was to understand the standard
deviation so we could use the empirical
rule well let's test the standard error
of the mean so here's a slightly longer
piece of code I'm going to look at a
bunch of different sample sizes from 25
to 650 trials each so get highs is just
a function that returns the temperatures
I'm going to get the standard deviation
of the whole population then the
standard error of the means and the
sample standard deviations both and then
I'm just going to go through and run it
so for size and sample size I'm going to
append the standard error of the mean
and remember that uses the population
standard deviation and the size of the
sample so I'll compute all the SEMS and
then I'm going to compute all the actual
standard deviations as well and then
we'll produce a bunch of blocks or a
plot actually all right so let's see
what that plot looks like
pretty striking so we see the blue solid
line is the standard deviation of the 50
means and the red dotted line is the
standard error of the mean so we can see
quite strikingly here that they really
track each other very well and this is
saying that I can anticipate what the
standard deviation would be by computing
the standard error which is really
useful because now I have one sample I
compute its standard error and I get
something very similar to what I get of
the standard deviation if I took 50
samples and looked at the standard
deviation of those 50 samples all right
so not obvious that this would be true
right that I could use this simple
formula and they two things would track
each other so well and it's not a
coincidence by the way that as I get out
here near the end they're really lying
on top of each other as the sample size
gets much larger they really will
coincide okay so one does everyone
understand the difference between the
standard deviation the standard error no
okay so how do we compute a standard
deviation to do that we have to look at
many samples in this case 50 and we
compute how much variation there is in
those 50 samples for the standard error
we look at one sample and we compute
this thing called the standard error and
we argue that we get the same number
more or less that we would have gotten
had we take in 50 samples or a hundred
samples and computed the standard
deviation so I can avoid taking all 50
samples if my only reason for doing it
was to
get the standard deviation I can take
one sample instead and use the standard
error of the mean so going back to my
temperature instead of having to look at
lots of samples I only have to look at
one and I can get a confidence interval
that makes sense okay
there's a catch notice that the formula
for the standard error includes the
standard deviation of the population not
the standard deviation of the sample
well that's kind of a bummer because how
can I get the standard deviation of the
population without looking at the whole
population and if I'm going to look at
the whole population then what's the
point of sampling in the first place so
we have a catch that we've got something
that's a really good approximation but
it uses a value we don't know so what
should we do about that well what would
be really the only obvious thing to try
what's our best guess at the standard
deviation of the population if we have
only one sample to look at now what
would you use somebody I know I forgot
to bring the candy today so no one wants
to answer any questions the standard
deviation of samples all I got so let's
ask the question how good is that
shockingly good so I looked at our
example here for the temperatures and
I'm plotting the sample standard
deviation versus the population standard
deviation for different sample sizes
ranging from 0 to 600 by one I think so
what you can see here is when the sample
size is small
I'm pretty far off I'm off by 14% here
and I think that's 25 but when the
sample size is larger say 600 I'm off by
about 2% so what we see at least for
this data set of temperatures if the
sample size is large enough the sample
standard deviation is a pretty good
approximation of the population standard
deviation well now we should ask the
question what good is this well as I
said once the sample reaches a
reasonable size and we see here
reasonable is probably somewhere around
500 it becomes a good approximation but
is it true only for this example the
fact that it happened to work for high
temperatures in the US doesn't mean that
it will always be true so there are at
least two things we should consider to
asking the question when will this be
true when it won't when won't it be true
one is does the distribution of the
population matters so here we saw in our
very first plot the distribution of the
high temperatures and it was kind of
symmetric around a point not perfectly
but not everything looks that way right
so we should say well suppose we had a
different distribution would that change
this conclusion and the other thing we
should ask is well suppose we had a
different size population suppose
instead of 400,000 temperatures I had 20
million temperatures would I need more
than six hundred samples for the two
things to be about the same well let's
or both of those questions first let's
look at the distributions and we'll look
at three common distributions a uniform
distribution a normal distribution in an
exponential distribution and we'll look
at each of them for what is this a
hundred thousand points so we know we
can generate a uniform distribution by
calling random dot random gives me a
uniform distribution of real numbers
between zero and one we know that we can
generate a normal distribution by
calling random Gauss
in this case I'm looking at it between
with a mean of zero and a standard
deviation of one but as we saw in the
last lecture the shape will be the same
independent of these values and finally
an exponential distribution which we get
by calling random dot x-bow variate and
this number 0.5 is something called
lambda which has to do with how quickly
the exponential either decays or goes up
depending upon which direction and I'm
not going to give you the formula for it
at the moment but we'll look at the
pictures and we'll plot each of these
discrete approximations to these
distributions so here's what they look
like quite different right we've looked
at uniform and we've looked at Gaussian
before and here we see an exponential
which basically decays and will
asymptote toward zero never quite
getting there but as you can see it is
certainly not very symmetric around the
the mean all right so let's see what
happens if we run the experiment on
these three distributions each of a
hundred thousand point examples and look
at different sample sizes we actually
see that the difference between the
standard DV
station and the sample standard
deviation of the population standard
deviation is not the same right we see
down here this looks kind of like what
we saw before but the exponential one is
really quite different
you know it's worst case is up here at
25 the normal is about 14 so that's not
too surprising since our temperatures
were kind of normally distributed when
we looked at it and the uniform is
initially much better approximation and
the reason for this has to do with the
fundamental difference in these
distributions of something called skew
skew is a measure of the asymmetry of a
probability distribution and what we can
see here is that skew actually matters
the more skew you have the more samples
you're going to need to get a good
approximation so if the population is
very skewed very asymmetric in the
distribution you need a lot of samples
to figure out what's going on if it's
very uniform as in for example of a
uniform population you need many fewer
samples okay so that's an important
thing when we go about deciding how many
samples we need we need to have some
estimate of the skew in our population
all right how about size to size matter
shockingly at least it was to me the
first time I looked at this the answer
is no that
if we look at this and I'm looking at
just for the uniform distribution but
we'll see the same thing for all three
it more or less doesn't matter quite
amazing right if you have a bigger
population you don't need more samples
and it's really almost counterintuitive
to think that you don't need any more
samples to find out what's going to
happen if you have a thousand million
people or a hundred million people and
that's why when we look at say political
polls we actually they're amazingly
small right they poll a thousand people
and claim their representative of
Massachusetts all right this is good
news so to estimate the mean of a
population given a single sample we
choose a sample size based upon some
estimate of skew in the population this
is important because if we get that
wrong we might choose a sample size
that's too small and in some sense you
always want to choose the smallest
sample size you can that will give you a
accurate answer because it's more
economical than small samples than big
samples and I've been talking about
polls but the same is true in an
experiment now how many pieces of data
do you need to collect when you run a an
experiment in a lab and how much will
depend again on the skew of the data and
that will help you decide once you know
the size you choose a random sample from
the population then you compute the mean
and the standard deviation of that
sample
and then use the standard deviation of
that sample to estimate the standard
error and I want to emphasize that what
you're getting here is an estimate of
the standard error not the standard
error itself which would require you to
know the population standard deviation
but if you've chosen the sample size to
be appropriate this will turn out to be
a good estimate and then once we've done
that we use the estimated standard error
to generate confidence intervals around
the sample mean and we're done now this
works great we choose independent random
samples and as we've seen before that if
you don't choose independent samples it
doesn't work so well and again this is
an issue right where if you assume that
in an election each state is independent
of every other state and you get the
wrong answer because they're not all
right let's go back to our temperature
example and pose a simple question or
200 samples enough I don't know why I
chose 200 I did so we'll do an
experiment here this is similar to an
experiment we saw on Monday so I'm
starting with the number of mistakes I
make 40 and range number of trials
sample will be random dot sample of the
temperatures in the sample size this is
a key step the first time I did this I
messed it up and instead of doing this
very simple thing I did a more
complicated thing of just choosing some
point in my list of temperatures and
taking the next the next 200
temperatures why why did that give me
the wrong answer because it's organized
by city so if I happen to choose the
first day of Phoenix all 200
temperatures were Phoenix
which is not a very good approximation
of the temperature in the country as a
whole but this will work I'm using
random blood sample I'll then get the
sample mean
then I'll compute my estimate of the
standard error but by taking that as
seed here and then if the absolute value
of the population minus the sample mean
is more than 1.96 standard errors I'm
going to say nest up right it's outside
and then at the end I'm going to look at
the fraction outside 95% confidence
intervals and what do I hope it should
print what would I what would be the
perfect answer when I run this what
fraction should lie outside that well
it's a pretty simple calculation
five right because if they all were
inside then I'm being too conservative
in my interval right I want five percent
of the tests to fall outside the 95%
confidence interval right if I wanted
fewer then I would look at three
standard deviations instead of 1.96 then
I would expect less than 1% to fall
outside so this is something we have to
always keep in mind when we do this kind
of thing if your answer is too good
you've messed up right shouldn't be too
bad but it shouldn't be too good either
right that's what probabilities are all
about if you called every election
correctly then your math is wrong all
right well when we run this we get this
lovely answer that the fraction outside
the 95% confidence interval is zero
point zero five one one that's exactly
well close to what you want it's almost
exactly five percent and if I run it
multiple times I get slightly different
numbers but they're all in that range
showing that here in fact it really does
work okay so that's what I want to say
and it's really important this notion of
the standard error when I talk to other
departments but we should cover in six
triple zero to about the only thing
everybody agrees on was we should talk
about standard error so now I hope I
made everyone happy and we will talk
about fitting curves to experimental
data starting next week all right thanks
a lot
you